bonjour Khan c'est bastien sapin le
sapin le plus légendaire de la Côte
d'Azur et cette année je compte bien
faire briller mon étoile et pourquoi pas
en décrocher une autre sur le parcours
de Ninja Warrior cette année je reviens
en légende et ça en bûche un coin à
certains
[Musique]
c'est pas bon
snapchat et après si elle dit oui elle
dit oui elle dit non ça se passe
c'est la vérité
c'est quoi être partout
les boîtes je suis allé une fois en
boîte
en breton au Cap d'Agde
les idées deviennent une vitesse
et ça n'a pas
non non il y a beaucoup de Marseillais
enfin
les gens très bien chez les Marseillais
vous savez
ça fait un peu bouffe quand même les
photos au total Benjamin Mendy était
accusé de cette viol d'une tentative de
viol et d'une agression sexuelle un
procureur l'avait même décrit comme un
prédateur mais après trois ans d'enquête
et deux procès le footballeur a été jugé
non coupable une décision de la justice
britannique salut et par un autre
champion du monde Paul Pogba a tellement
heureux pour toi mon frère toutes les
personnes qui parlaient mal de toi
maintenant je veux les voir laver ton
nom j'espère trouver la sœur cet été non
cet été je préfère rester en défense ah
tu vas laisser les
tu veux sortir avec moi c'est les
garçons qui vont dire ça je pense pas
que ça va marcher tu prends tu te prends
très très mal
sur les réseaux sociaux ce sont
désormais les femmes accusatrices qui
sont pointées du doigt ce que dénonce
cette militante féministe un peu une
acrobatie mentale pour se le représenter
mais quand la justice tranche qu'un
homme et non coupable ça veut pas dire
qu'elle part du principe du coup que les
chrysatrices mentaient sinon le procès
se retournerait automatiquement contre
elle serait elle-même mise en accusation
la pression est énorme j'aimerais bien
j'aimerais bien la voir aussi
bonjour messieurs il y avait un petit
trou là et derrière je passais des films
pornographiques il y en a plusieurs et
donc les gens se retrouver tous comme ça
et on arrivait dans cette salle vide en
carrelage où tout le monde sait danser
dans cette position là ce qui était un
petit peu un petit peu étrange mais tout
à fait l'esprit du bain douche sa
dernière toile s'est vendue 23500 euros
donc en 2021 les bénéfices sont reversés
en faveur de la cause animale la truie
artiste peint avec un pinceau bien sûr
dans la gueule vous voulez qu'elle n'est
pas un vrai froid et Warhol a beaucoup
apprécié parce qu'un jour je suis arrivé
il était là et au moment où il demande
mais qui a fait ça c'est un génie et là
c'est lui et là il me prend ses bras
comme ça et il m'embrasse et donc voilà
comme quoi un grand honneur tient un
petit trou
depuis quelques jours c'est tout l'ouest
et une partie du sud des États-Unis qui
sont touchés par des chaleurs
accablantes
à Las Vegas dans le Nevada les touristes
suffoquent
j'aime la ville surtout la nuit mais
c'est dingue cette chaleur probablement
parce qu'on n'y est pas habitué
de nombreux espaces publics ont fermé
leur porte comme les airs de jeux pour
enfants ou les toboggans sont brûlants
même au premières heures de la journée
tous les jours on reçoit un ou deux
patients qui ont des brûlures plus ou
moins sévères après avoir été en contact
avec l'asphalte ou quelque chose de très
chaud le maillot jusqu'ici
spécifiquement de bain 7 juin désormais
le maillot de bar celui-ci allant très
peu à l'eau ou pas du tout
recommandé pour les réunions élégantes
et les cocktails esquivaux il se
présente comme un compromis entre le
maillot Kiabi en déshabillant et la robe
du soir qui déshabille en habit en
Arizona le phénomène est rapidement
devenu viral sur les réseaux sociaux
cuir ses œufs en posant sa casserole sur
le bitume un rarement de détente dans
cet état de la côte ouest tous les
maximales dépassent les 43 degrés pour
le 16e jour de suite
sur le bord de cette route
le plus long python jamais observé en
Floride
[Musique]
à peine repérer l'animal tombe d'abord
de fuir
mais au bout de quelques secondes
face à l'autre
moi il me fait peur parce qu'il est
grand
il contre-attaque l'homme qui tente de
l'attraper ce chasseur amateur la grippe
par le cou
et lutte pendant plusieurs minutes au
risque de sa vie
une capture à main nue Jake 22 ans ne
s'attendait pas à un tel combat ça veut
dire il se passe rien les gars
climatique c'est pas vrai il y a pas des
mecs sur des idées
36 15 démagogie bonjour Alors oui
bonjour je suis le je suis là démagogie
à l'antenne bonjour ça va combien créer
grâce à ça combien de fois
de personnes
elles sont traumatisées là
Marion il est où Patrice là
le gros qui a une tête blanche et un
tablier tu le vois pas c'est celui-là
regardez ce qu'on va faire on va tous se
mettre au chômage d'accord on va tous
regarder à la télé mais on va tous
attendre
rien chez nous on ne commande pas
chier et on mange pareil
la disparition à 76 ans de Jane Birkin
le cinéma et la chanson se souviendront
de cette jeune femme née à Londres
naturalisée française et qui par sa
sensibilité avec conquis le public
français
la gadoue la gadoue la gadoue la gadoue
voilà une émotion partagée en ligne par
d'innombrables artistes Patrick Bruel
Carla Bruni Pierre Richard entre autres
lui rend hommage Jane si drôle si
intelligente si fragile si généreuse si
tout un bout de mon cœur s'en va avec
elle Line Renaud se souvient d'une
personnalité rare elle dégageait
énormément énormément
de gens gentillesse une infinie bienve
je n'ai jamais entendu bien dire du mal
de qui que ce soit
[Musique]
oui je suis au regret
que je m'en vais
car tu me mets trop vite